[Música]
hablamos de salud en derecho américa de
france24 y está conmigo en el estudio
más romeros a la mar bienvenida vamos a
hablar de la pandemia y el sistema
inmunitario porque de qué comenzó esta
dolencia sanitaria todos nos fijamos en
el sistema inmune pero realmente lo
comprendemos realmente tenemos
consciencia de lo que estamos hablando
yo creo que no mucha no more no mucha
pero está bien porque los que la verdad
es que es muy difícil de comprender el
sistema inmune de un sistema súper intra
intrincado desde órganos células
mecanismos sistemas distintos que cuesta
la verdad realmente tener una
comprensión profunda de eso y vamos a
explicarlo por encima pero la verdad
también nos vamos a dejar muchas cosas
por el camino porque es muy difícil
explicarlo en su totalidad para empezar
hay dos tipos de inmunidad no si nos
imaginamos el cuerpo como si fuera un
castillo hay una primera inmunidad que
es la que llamaremos inmunidad innata
que es como si nos imaginamos eso de
nuevo no como si fuéramos una fortaleza
son esas barreras físicas que impiden la
entrada de agentes externos estamos
hablando en este caso pues de las
mucosas en las vías respiratorias de los
lagrimales por ejemplo la misma piel el
ácido gástrico otras mucosas que
recubren internos o incluso por ejemplo
el reflejo del actos no todo esto tiene
el objetivo de expulsar de entrada a
cualquier agente externo que intente
entrar en nuestro cuerpo ya sea una
bacteria o un virus o hasta una mota que
se nos meta en el ojo pero luego también
está la inmunidad adquirida y aquí es
donde se empiezan a complicar también
las cosas es un sistema mucho más
complejo aquí hay algunos algunos
ejemplos por ejemplo los anticuerpos las
células b y células t que explicaremos a
más profundidad después y básicamente
son los que desde dentro de este
castillo orden las estrategias miran los
mapas no hacen la inteligencia para
realmente combatir y vencer la
enfermedad o el agente externo que haya
entrado y además como su nombre indica
es una inmunidad que se va entrenando a
lo largo de la vida a través de las
repetidas infecciones que vamos
sufriendo más pero qué partes del cuerpo
entonces están implicadas en la lucha
contra lo externo pues muchas de hecho
casi que todo el cuerpo es una de las
cosas también más bonitas del sistema
inmune no como decíamos está implicada
desde la piel como barrera externa la
sangre como vaso de comunicación y luego
órganos varios en este caso por ejemplo
estamos el sistema linfático por ejemplo
la médula ósea que es esa parte
esponjosa que queda dentro de los huesos
ahí se producen los glóbulos blancos
como estas células 20 que ahora
explicaremos mejor qué son los ganglios
linfáticos los vasos linfáticos también
es todo un sistema de comunicaciones
dentro del cuerpo los grandes lo que
hacen es filtrar este líquido para
encontrar estos agentes externos estos
patógenos las amígdalas incluso
contienen glóbulos blancos huelva o
también no guardan varias células de
este implicadas en el sistema inmune y
las manda desde allí a otros lugares del
cuerpo y precisamente por ser tan
extenso puede ser tan maleable no se
puede vivir sin amígdalas se puede vivir
el bazo porque el propio cuerpo aprende
a compensar este tipo de cosas es olvidó
preguntar porque mucha gente que no
tiene ni hacen amígdalas por problemas
de salud hay que retirarlas pero qué
sucede cuando hay entonces una infección
vamos a repasar bien el paso a paso no
también depende un poco de qué tipo de
infección con un virus de la gripe pues
primero se nos van a activar las mucosas
la tos también la fiebre porque la
temperatura alta puede ayudar a matar a
alguno de estos patógenos que intenten
entrar en el cuerpo todos estos son
síntomas de que el sistema inmune está
funcionando pero una vez esta infección
este virus o esta bacteria entra en el
cuerpo la primera respuesta la tienen
los macrófagos es la primera línea de
defensa es una especie de guardias que
están patrullando y que se dirigen hacia
donde los llaman para atrapar este virus
o esta bacteria y tratar de desintegrar
lo pero eso a veces no es suficiente
entonces ahí entra la parte de la
inteligencia y unas células que se
llaman las células dendríticas que lo
que hacen es recoger muestras de este
agente que ha entrado en nuestro cuerpo
se recubre con ellas como si fuera ella
misma identificable como como este
patógeno que ha entrado y se va hasta
las células que no busca cuál es la
respuesta más indicada a las células t
hay algunas que son la que se llaman
células t vírgenes que es que todavía no
se han activado contra ninguna
enfermedad busca cuál encaja más con
estas muestras con este pequeño
reconocedor del patógeno que haya
entrado y cuando la encuentra esta
célula t se activa viaja hasta las
células de estas células ve que ya la
reconocen aprenden a reconocer la ide y
se dedican a fabricar los anticuerpos
los famosos de anticuerpos que ya
conocemos
que están básicamente destinados a
bloquear este patógeno para que no pueda
entrar en las células y seguir con su
infección muy importante estas células
bay estas células t que son unos
glóbulos blancos los linfocitos en los
linfocitos perdón tienen memoria
entonces la próxima vez que nos re
infecte en muerte recordarán cómo
combatir es tan cierta como una máquina
perfecta entonces entendiendo era un
poco mejor de cómo funciona el sistema
inmune nos puede enseñar algo sobre la
pandemia de cubit 19 que estamos
viviendo ahora sí muchísimas cosas una
infinidad pero yo me voy a basar
prácticamente solo en una no una cosa
muy básica con el tema de la vacunación
y con algo que nos ha preocupado mucho
que es esta inmunidad que se va
desvaneciendo porque contamos los
anticuerpos y parece que cada vez
tenemos menos anticuerpos recordemos los
anticuerpos son una reacción a la
infección oa la vacuna en este caso
cuando también uno está uno está
vacunado entonces medir la inmunidad que
tenemos contra el cob y 19 únicamente
con los anticuerpos puede ser
insuficiente porque porque como decíamos
de esa reacción a la infección puede ser
útil es decir cuanto más anticuerpos
mejor pero no es la única manera de
medir por qué pues porque estas células
estas células pueden recordar cómo
combatir este virus y eso no significa
que cuando no se infecte moss de aquí
tres años aunque tengamos pocos en el
cuerpo no podamos construir una
respuesta adecuada cómo podemos cuidarlo
y cómo podemos reforzar este sistema
inmune para finalizar reforzarlo de
hecho casi que no hace falta porque el
sistema inmune ya es muy poderoso de
hecho cuando se descontrola vemos que
puede provocar muchas enfermedades
autoinmunes que es cuando reacciona de
manera exagerada contra el propio cuerpo
pero es muy importante cuidarlo y
mantenerlo equilibrado porque pues
porque está inmunodeprimido puede
realmente costarnos la salud hay tres
claves ampliamente reconocidas una una
buena dieta equilibrada sana hacer
ejercicio puede ser moderado no hace
falta que seamos grandes atletas y sobre
todo descansar y alejarnos del estrés
más gracias entonces por toda la
información de salud de esas
recomendaciones tan valiosas para todos
para tener una mejor calidad de vida y
no necesariamente para también reportar
el sistema inmune más nueva mañana con
más salud pasamos al lugar a nuestra
segunda mitad del día